rxjs is a huge library with a very steep
learning curve in this episode I'm going
to talk about a few key concepts that
are specific to angular firebase
developers I believe it's best to focus
on what you actually need to learn
rather than try to master the entire
rxjs library to do this I have created a
simple component that uses the angular
fire to package to retrieve cats and
dogs from firebase cats and dogs each
have their own collection and there's
another collection for humans which
represent the owner of a given pet your
component should look something like
this we import the angular fire database
and then inject it in the constructor
when using rxjs and angular you only
import the methods and classes that you
need in rxjs there are two types of
methods static and instance in this
first example we use an instance method
combine latest so we create two
instances of an observable then we can
use that operator on the observable
instance itself
notice how the method was imported from
add / operator the operator directory
contains all of the instance methods
it's not important to know at this point
but using combine latest will result in
an observable array of two strings now
let's accomplish the same thing using a
static method to obtain the static
method we import from the add /
observable directory instead of calling
the method on an instance we call it on
the observable class itself and then we
pass the two observables to it as
arguments in rxjs some methods are only
instance others are only static and some
overlap for both now let's talk about
subscriptions that's how you actually
extract data from observables there are
two main ways to do this in angular you
can either subscribe in the component
type script or in the component HTML in
this example we will subscribe to cats
in the HTML and dogs and the component
type script notice how cats are a
firebase list observable and dogs are
just a regular array calling DB lists
will return an observable from the
firebase database for cats we just keep
it as is but for dogs we call subscribe
which will cause the observable to emit
an array of dogs that we can set as the
variable on this component to subscribe
to cats we do this in the template
itself by
using the async pipe provided by angular
under the hood this is subscribing to
the observable just like we did in the
typescript for dogs it's generally
preferred to use the async pipe when
possible because it will also
unsubscribe to the observable to prevent
memory leaks and it just results in less
code when we iterate over dogs notice
we're not using the async pipe since
that was already unwrapped in the
component if we go into the app we can
see the results are identical for both
collections when you create
subscriptions it's a good practice to
unsubscribe when that data is no longer
needed if you use the async pipe like we
did with calves this will happen
automatically but with dogs we built the
subscription manually so we want to end
that subscription when the components no
longer in use we can do this by setting
the subscription to its own variable and
listen for the ondestroy lifecycle hook
and call unsubscribe
the next concept I want to talk about is
mapping observables this allows you to
transform data before you subscribe to
it the first thing we'll do is transform
a list observable of cats into a number
based on the length of that collection
so first we obtain the list observable
from firebase
can we call map and that will emit an
array which we can just call lengths on
and that will return a number
representing the length of that
collection in the next example we take a
dog is an object observable then map its
name just to a single string as you can
see the map operator is very powerful
you can use it to transform any type of
asynchronous data into the format that
you want going back to the HTML we can
just call these observables with the
async pipe and get their mapped values
back going back into the app we can see
the observable is transformed into a
string and a number as expected now
let's talk about the switch map operator
this allows us to handle data
relationships that exist between two
independent streams a common example in
firebase is when you need the auth
observable to emit the current user
before you can query some other data
we're going to simulate that situation
here by taking an object observable of a
human then use the name from that
observable to query the pets owned by
that human so switch map is kind of like
subscribing to the
observable and then using that data to
return a second observable so we set
this whole thing equal to the dog's
variable then iterate over it in the
template like normal with the async pipe
back in the app we can see the dogs
observable only emits the two dogs that
match this human owner named in some
cases you might find yourself needing to
combine two observables into one rxjs
has several different combination
operators but we'll just be focusing on
combine latest for this example we will
pull two different object observables
from firebase and then combine them and
do add new observable called animals in
this case I used the static method from
the observable class to pass both of
these objects observables as arguments
this results in a observable with an
array that we can iterate over in the
template if we go back to the app we can
see we have one cat and one dog in an
array even though they come from
completely different collections and
firebase the final topic I want to cover
is about behavior subjects which allow
us to share current data throughout an
angular app I'll be going over this very
quickly so I also recommend checking out
the JavaScript evangelist and his video
on behavior subjects check out the link
in the description a behavior subject is
just an observable that we can push data
to it also has a concept of a current
value which is very useful for real-time
app development because you generally
want the most up-to-date information
displayed in the app in this example
we're going to create a new variable
called current dog which is a behavior
subject and it gets updated whenever you
click on the dog's image this may seem
trivial in this example but when you use
the behavior subject in an angular
service you can then share current data
throughout the application we push new
data to the behavior subject by calling
next and that will update any observers
throughout the app in the template we
allow the user to change the current dog
or the value of the behavior subject by
clicking on a dog's image then we unwrap
the behavior subject with the async pipe
just like we would with any other
observable but also notice how we use
that question mark before calling any
attributes because the default value is
null so we don't want to call an
attribute that doesn't exist
now if we go back into the app we can
see when we click on a dog's image it
updates the current dog with that data
[Music]
that's it for my top 7 and rxjs patterns
for angular firebase developers if this
video helped you please like and
subscribe and if you want to support the
channel consider becoming a pro member
at angular firebase comm thanks for
watching and I'll see you next time
[Music]